president's remarks did not mention the
recent alarming spike in coronavirus
cases
yesterday dr anthony fauci became the
latest high-ranking official
to be vaccinated in public and
encouraged others to get the vaccine
u.s officials reported more than 3 400
deaths yesterday
the second highest one-day toll since
the pandemic began here
mullalangi reports on the fear that
christmas celebrations
will make the virus spread even faster
if you have travel plans right now
cancel those travel plans
as new york mayor bill de blasio pleaded
with new yorkers to stay home
for christmas stay away from me tensions
boiled over in california over masking
up during the holiday season
300 000 people are sad former growing
pains star kirk cameron hosted a
controversial
masked optional protest against the
state's stay-at-home orders
with more than 100 people singing carols
at a los angeles area mall
there in community
southern california is no stranger to
resistance to covid restrictions
the l.a county sheriff's office says it
has made at least 235
arrests busting underground parties in
december alone
and southern california is suffering
from the fallout icus across the region
are at capacity with hospitals
scrambling for extra space
the university of california irvine
medical center is one of three
facilities in orange county building
new mobile field hospitals to handle an
influx of covent patients
we're exhausted we're holding on brad
spellberg is chief medical officer at
the la county usc medical center
what is the worst case scenario here our
fear is we end up looking like new york
did
you know in april when you were just
systematically
completely overwhelmed it's like a bomb
has been dropped on our home
teresa perazi knows the emotional toll
kovid can take on a family
all too well her 85 year old parents
jerry and shirley
have been married for 57 years they were
both
hospitalized with kovid this month just
days apart
as i'm waving to my dad goodbye in the
ambulance
i'm thinking this might be the last time
i see him
uh new this morning the department of
health and human services secretary alex
azar has just announced this morning
that the federal government has reached
a deal with pfizer
for an additional hundred million doses
of its vaccine that's in addition
to the hundred million that was already
on the way to the federal government and
of course eureka this moves
uh the government closer to its ultimate
goal of vaccinating
all americans all right mola lange
forest thank you so much